this is one of the original House
Husbands on Tick Tock who got this whole
Trend going sorry tough guys it's part
two of a day in the life of a
stay-at-home husband when I say check
your misogyny at the door I mean it it's
the weekend so you know I gotta let my
queen sleep in so I make her some
pancakes she likes them with chocolate
chippies in them
on Sundays we strip the sheets and then
I load the dishwasher next I borrow my
wife's credit card and I go get some
groceries I check those eggs check out
make my way home and put the groceries
away the fridge organized with all her
favorite drinks and snacks and then I
take the trash out to where the men go
your wife needs to be able to respect
you and in a in a marriage that that's
something that they they need that more
than they need someone making pancakes
for them in the morning